in our series vaccinating america the
u.s is distributing a second coronavirus
vaccine and scientists are closely
watching
a new variant of the virus to see how it
affects the pandemic
one of those scientists is michael
osterholm a member of president-elect
biden's coronavirus task force
he's director of the center for
infectious disease research and policy
at the university of minnesota
good morning to you dr osterhome thank
you for joining us
good morning jamie good to talk to you
again i know we we've talked several
times being from minnesota i do
want to ask you about this new strain of
the coronavirus being identified in both
the uk and south africa what does it
mean for us here in the united states
well first of all let me just say that i
don't speak for the biden harris
transition team these are my own
professional
opinions but i'm very concerned about
this i think that it does represent a
real challenge
to us globally and that this particular
variant which is very different than any
of the
previous variants we've seen could very
well substantially increase transmission
of this virus
and for the fact of how the vaccines and
others may protect us it's really
unclear at this point
i find that interesting because a lot of
people are asking this morning we've
said that this virus is
potentially 70 percent more contagious
what does that actually mean how does a
virus become more contagious
well what happens is in part the virus
actually may grow to a much higher level
in an individual's throat and
respiratory
tract and there's actually data from
england supporting that that the people
who are infected with this strain
actually have more virus which then
might very well make them more
infectious
and if that's the case all you have to
do is increase
even marginally the number of people
that any one individual infects
and then you have potentially very rapid
growth of the
virus in the community that wouldn't
have happened otherwise and that i think
is what's actually being seen right now
in england that's really interesting
what impact do you think this could have
on the vaccine process well i hope
none but hope's not a strategy we've got
to find out
whether or not this particular virus
does challenge us in terms of how our
immune response
reacts and and how it handles the virus
right now we have to go full steam ahead
with the vaccines we have
they're very powerful tools and we just
have to make certain that this new
variant strain is not going to
escape at least some of the protection
of the vaccine we do have a new
modern vaccine being rolled out today
what are your thoughts on the rollout so
far of both of these vaccines
well first of all they're very powerful
tools as i just mentioned
and i liken them to having a 2021 high
performance engine
uh the problem is is that that engine
has been put on a
model t chassis and what i mean by that
is that the
challenge we have right now is this last
mile and last
inch last mile meaning getting the
vaccine
out to the people who need it right now
state and local health departments have
no resources to do this
the private sector partners also are
challenged
and so we've got to fix this last mile
and then we're going to have to conf
convince people to take the vaccine
that's that last inch and we know we
have
a sizable number of people in this
country who are vaccine hesitant
we've not done a good job of explaining
what these vaccines are what they might
be able to do
and why people need to get them so we
we've got to get that done too
really quickly how many strains do
pandemics usually have
well each virus is different well our
traditional
pandemic strains are as influenza there
it's a single strain
that then over time will mutate but this
one is a coronavirus and we've never
seen a coronavirus pandemic before
we're truly in uncharted territory all
right michael osterhome thank you so
much